Michael Lee with the athletic Kauai out  there on the Korg Messiah just said  you're the Messiah just said you're the  best player to League in he plays in  Toronto what does it feel like to hear  that said about you and how do you feel  you've established yourself in that  position doing this playoff run I mean I  don't really judge my you know game like  I'm more of a team team aspect see what  my team is doing just want to win home I  don't care about being the best player I  want to be the best team always said  that and you know just before the season  when we made the trade I saw I felt that  way about me he told me how he felt and  why you made the tray and you know just  turning out it's turning out well now I  mean we're in the finals and we're not  done yet